okay first of all I recognize this this
is actually boots the house down mama
yes god yes because it's a boot all the
way all the way up there were some
people there like I don't get it it
doesn't go with the theme of Seng boots
boots the house down mama yes the boot
is built in custom you said to me at
rehearsal that you were gonna come full
valentina for press day and we are full
valentina right now we sure are we have
the rita hayworth ginger hair we got a
classic red lip we got the little things
on the hair I wore my feathers because
I'm giving you angel how excited are you
just for everyone to finally see what
you've been putting together I'm so
excited because I finally get to show
what I'm capable of I think with drag
race it's a lot of like improv it's a
lot of comedy challenges but here I can
kind of show what I've been preparing my
whole life for for the cameras and to
seeing and to dance and to be authentic
and to to really not really be just
Valentina but deliver something as an
actor as a singer as a dancer as an
overall artist and I'm very excited
probably wants to see us
what takes longer getting into full
Valentina are getting into full angel
getting into full Valentin that for sure
she's fall this is full glam this is
vogue honey this is vogue photoshoot
maintenance she's high maintenance she's
an expensive lady and takes a lot of
time to get into all of this gun drag
race you got some harsh criticisms for
the padding challenge
it was very Couture right do you want to
defend this for a month
I am deeply and utterly offended that
judge with the bun and the gold I do not
appreciate her non constructive
criticism of my beautiful outfit sure
well what I did for that runway was a
lot more conceptual and I think it's
open to interpretation but what I was
wearing was my actual padding it was
it's what me and my designer have worked
on it's my actual mannequin with my
actual padding that actually makes my
garments so when we made that outfit
Alette
without a mannequin to make the rest of
my costumes so we literally sacrifice
sacrifice my might like my dress form
and have to make a new one for that
runway so it's like I'm wearing what
makes all of my beautiful clothes on me
down the runway and I just really wanted
to be deconstructive berry Dior and I
hope people enjoyed it and if they
didn't they're gonna enjoy it anyway
because it's on TV and I feel my fantasy
in my world girl I think what happens
this is live television something's
gonna go wrong I hope it doesn't happen
to you but it might what do you do when
you fall down the stairs or something
else you pose you pose you get back up
and you keep going and you make up for
it so say when you mess up and you fall
okay and before you thought you were
doing fine you get up and you go level
100 to make up for it don't forget about
the thought the next thing you do is you
give them you've got two turns you can
do three after that then you don't race
that are you doing the jump off the
table the famous angel I think you guys
are just have to wait and see we've been
doing a lot of her so I don't want to
give it away because then they're not
gonna tune in so tune in
[Music]